we played the Packers this week you know
I was talking to Aaron Rodgers on there
and I was asking I was like Hey like
why
are y'all not passing the ball like
y'all down 17 points why why are y'all
not passing the ball like
why you're not passing the ball and like
I'm not gonna tell you what he said
because I don't you know I'm not gonna
use this platform to you know to get
[ __ ] started but I was asking I'm like
hey like why y'all not passing the ball
man what you what you think going on not
only with the only thing not only with
Aaron Rodgers but Russell Wilson and and
Tom Brady what you think going on with
these three guns no no no no no no I'll
tell you what Aaron said I ain't got
nobody to throw it to I don't trust none
of them I wish I could throw it to
myself that way what he said to you like
I don't trust these boys they couldn't
catch a cold in the snowstorm in Alaska
like that's what he said but you gotta
think Aaron Rodgers like you can't it's
you got it then you Aaron Rodgers like
you can get these guys you can get some
guys you can get some guys opener you
can tell them little tricks like hey
right when I come off the play action if
you hit this slant I'm gonna hit you
right over the front like
getting them open ain't the problem he
hitting them why they open they dropping
the rock yeah are they running the wrong
route or he's saying run post and they
run a corner are you saying run to stop
they running a go and then he looking
crazy throwing the ball
and he's sitting there sick